>>Jeff Chang: Hello, everybody. Thanks a lot
for coming. This is the Chrome Fireside Chat,
and we're looking forward to answering some
of your questions.
As you can see, there's a URL up there on
the screen. You can go there to submit and
vote on the questions that people have already
submitted. So we're going through those questions
and then of course we'll be taking audience
questions at the microphone, too, so don't
be shy. Please come up to the microphones
if you have a question.
But first, let's do a round of introductions
and I'll let everybody here introduce themselves.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Thanks. Yeah, my name
is Ian Ellison-Taylor. I'm the director of
product management for the web platform pieces
and other related stuff-ish. Pretty vague.
>>Jeff Chang: My name is Jeff Chang. I'm a
product manager on the Chrome browser team
focusing on a couple of areas such as UI features,
plug-ins, and privacy.
>>Erik Kay: My name is Erik Kay. I'm the engineering
manager for apps, extensions, and native client.
>>Alex Russell: I'm Alex Russell. I'm a software
engineer. I work on Chrome Frame and the Chrome
web platform more generally.
>>Pavel Feldman: I'm Pavel Feldman, software
engineer working on Chrome developer tools
and Webkit web inspector.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. I'm going to switch it
over to the questions now, so -- and I should
mention we have one other person from the
Chrome OS team who is running a bit late but
he should be here really soon.
So it looks like the first question is actually
about Chrome OS. "When are you showing the
ARM powered Chromebooks? Are ARM cortex-A9
processors with lots of RAM fast enough today?
What is the status of Chrome OS on ARM?"
I unfortunately don't know the answer to that
so I think we should wait until our Chrome
OS team member comes here and he will happily
answer that question.
And again, just to remind you guys, feel free
to come up to the microphones. Don't be shy.
Kan, just in time.
I'll go ahead and move on to the second question
while he's getting settled in. "Google Chrome
browser is already available for PC, Mac,
Chrome OS, and Google TV. Will Google Chrome
be available for Android devices in the future?"
One of you guys want to handle this?
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: I don't know how to
answer that. I don't -- we're not -- it's
not something we're talking about right now.
>>Jeff Chang: I mean, I think the important
thing to remember at the end of the day is,
you know, what we're trying to accomplish
with Chrome is to make the web better -- right?
-- to make web browsers better, so obviously
there's a web browser on Android and, you
know, we'd like to work with them to make
that as compelling and as good of a web browsing
experience as possible.
>>Erik Kay: One thing I'll toss out is that
while it's not strictly Chrome, we share an
awful lot of code with the Android team. We
share Webkit, of course. We share V8. We share
our networking stack. And we're working on
sharing even more over time.
>>Alex Russell: It's also worth commenting
that mobile has a lot of separate challenges,
specifically on constrained memory footprint
devices where the multiprocess model poses
new and interesting impositions where on the
desktop world, where would you have got a
couple of gig of memory just laying around,
things are different. So...
>>Jeff Chang: Sorry. I wanted to get back
to the first question I skipped over.
So Kan, you want to handle that one?
>>Kan Lai: Okay. So as we've announced before,
we are definitely working on ARM, and we think
it's actually a really interesting platform
for us to be able to get some of the low-power
attributes you get with ARM devices and be
able to get thinner devices as well.
It's something the team is continuing to work
on. We're obviously right now focused on getting
sort of the Samsung Acer devices out the door,
but these are hot on the trails.
>>Jeff Chang: Cool. Now we'll take a question
from the audience.
>> I have a question about Google Chrome Frame.
I'm a big fan of Google Chrome Frame.
On our site, we've -- any IE6 user who comes
to the site, we put up a little dialogue that
says, "Hey, you should get Google Chrome Frame."
We've got a big button. And underneath it,
we have a little link that says, "Or you can
continue at your peril."
And we put analytics up and we find that 95%
plus of people are clicking on the link and
continuing at their peril. They are just not
clicking on that button. And I wonder if there's
any best practices we could use to try to
make it a little more inviting for people
to click on the button. They're getting a
terrible experience when they click on that
link.
The only thing they're getting out of it is
they're not installing Google Chrome Frame,
which is not good for them or us.
What could we do?
>>Alex Russell: Don't give them the option.
[Laughter]
>> I...
>>Alex Russell: Seriously. I don't mean that
to be flip. I'd say that if your site has
such a wide chasm in experience between, you
know, "You're going to get a terrible experience
here" or "You could get a modern browser"
-- right? -- like that's --
>> "Terrible" is such a strong word. It's
merely bad.
>>Alex Russell: Well, okay. And this is actually
an interesting question because there is a
gradient of experience that you can deliver,
right?
Some features are going to never work on a
terrible old browser, whatever that browser
might be.
You know, it's not like IE is unique here.
Netscape4 isn't going to support WebGL either.
And so we have this problem where there's
some set of features which you can shim in,
you can probably fill in, and for those, if
that's what your site is mostly composed of,
I think it does make sense to do the incremental
engineering effort to go, you know, say, "Hey,
here's a link to deliver an alternative experience."
If on the other hand you sort of want to lay
off those shackles and deliver the best experience
you can, I think it's maybe in your interest,
then, to not offer the option. Just say, you
know, "Here's a set of good options and our
site requires one of them."
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: (Speaker is off microphone)
>>Alex Russell: So the install -- you're saying
that they're not even clicking on the link.
The install experience is getting better.
>> Yeah. They have no idea how good or bad
the install experience might be.
>>Alex Russell: That's right. Yeah. So I think
that's a question of UI for you to test. I
wish I had a better answer than -- other than
don't give them the option.
>>Erik Kay: Just on the flip side, though,
I mean, a number of Google properties have
stopped supporting IE6 at this point. It's
certainly not unprecedented to stop -- you
know, stop supporting older browsers.
>> I mean, we'd like to do that. I mean, of
course we want to extend the strategy to IE7,
and, you know, if this button-plus-link strategy
had worked really well for IE6, I think we
would be pushing it much harder, maybe even
up to IE8, today.
But we don't want to annoy people if they're
just going to -- if they're all just going
to click the link, then, you know, what have
I done?
>>Alex Russell: So what we have seen for Google
properties is that when we do say "Please
get Chrome Frame or a modern browser and those
are the only choices," that's what they do.
They do go and install the plug-in. So --
>> That's good to hear.
I also wanted to offer a suggestion. "Google
Chrome Frame" is a pretty odd-sounding name,
and I know you've heard this before. Have
we considered like Chrome Light?
>>Alex Russell: Do you have a --
Chrome Light?
>> Light. It's a light version of Chrome.
It's not the full version; it's light.
>>Alex Russell: Interesting.
[Laughter]
>>Alex Russell: I'm not a huge fan of the
name either so, noted.
>> Thank you.
>>Jeff Chang: Thank you. I'm going to jump
to the Moderator questions now.
So "What is the status of SPDY adoption outside
of Google and for what applications or use
cases do you think it is a particularly good
fit?"
>>Erik Kay: Yeah. We don't have the expert
in the field here, but I used to sit next
to him so I'll try.
Anyway, we're working with a number of partners
on this front, and we're getting a lot of
interest. The sort of people who are most
interested are large website providers who
really want to optimize the experience for,
you know, as many of their users as they can.
Also, for content accelerators, you know,
edge hosting, that sort of thing.
As you know, we've -- we've got a module to
make it supported in Apache. It's built into
Chrome. It's now supported on all -- I think
all Google properties. So if you're using
Chrome and Google properties, you're automatically
benefitting from it right now, and we're out
pushing it and advocating others to adopt
it.
So really there are no barriers. It's all
open source, and we're -- we're just -- we're
trying to push it out there as best we can.
>>Jeff Chang: How about let's take another
microphone question.
Oh, from the back microphone.
>> So I remember when a couple of our lab
students got CR48s and we went ahead and started
hacking them and noticed that they ran a flavor
of gen 2 Linux.
This morning during the keynote, I noticed
that neither gen 2 nor Linux nor any of the
open source contributions that made up the
original CR48 stack were talked about.
Have you guys ditched that in favor of some
BIOS-less, OS-less approach to Chrome OS or
did you guys just forget to mention Linux?
>>Kan Lai: So absolutely we're still using
Linux. It's definitely at the core of what
we're building on top of.
The Linux -- the kernel team has done an amazing
job helping us, and we've been working closely
with them as well.
We definitely do credit them in the -- if
you go through our "about" menus and all that
kind of stuff, and our documentation and our
code, all the credits are there.
You're right, we definitely didn't mention
it during the keynote itself. That might have
been an oversight or also given sort of the
more consumer-focused messaging that we were
trying to --
>> Does marketing have a Linux allergy?
[Laughter]
>>Kan Lai: I'll leave that for you to decide.
>> Thank you.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. Let me take a question
from the front microphone and then we'll jump
back to the Moderator.
>> Sure. So I was really excited this morning
to hear about the Chromebook program for education
in schools. It seems like an amazing price,
and it would be really wonderful.
So I spent a lot of the last year working
in a school just teaching some kids how to
do HTML and CSS, some elementary school kids,
and so we were using some blah Windows 7 laptops,
but it did have NotePad and it did have, you
know, the ability to play around with things
in a file and reload them in a browser and,
you know, we could go into JavaScript or we
could mess around with RGB color codes or
whatever, and something that's a little more
flexible than like the Chrome developer tools.
So how -- if you were going to use a Chromebook
for such a thing, how would you go about doing
that? What should I be looking for?
>>Kan Lai: So it's a great question. In fact,
that's a question that we actually on the
team ask a lot, because we have developers
who want to be able to code completely in
Chrome OS as well.
And I think that's something we want to shoot
for in the future. It's definitely one of
the goals that we have.
In fact, you're seeing some of this already
today with a lot of cloud-based IDEs, right?
Cloud 9 was one of the ones that recently
came out that does a really good job of this.
And our hope is more and more products like
that will come out so that developers will
be able to, you know, code directly in a browser
and have basically the app run live and update
and all that kind of stuff instantaneously.
So that's definitely a use case we're looking
forward for.
>> So I guess a quick follow-up, then.
Do you see that as something that requires
integration into Chrome OS as a system or
is it that we just need some awesome website,
Web app, to come along that will help people
do that?
>>Pavel Feldman: So it's kind of both. We're
currently working with both Cloud 9 and Orion
on the integration with the Chrome environment.
Everything that you can see in the Chrome
dev tools, we now expose via the remove debugging
product code and you can attach to it at via
socket or Chrome Extension. So we allow websites,
specific websites, that are cloud IDEs, per
se, or stand-alone web IDEs, be them Java-based
or any other kind of IDEs, to connect to Chrome
instrumentation and replace developer tools
and do an integration seamless experience
for debugging and exploring code and such.
So you should just be -- just stay with us
and you'll see it happening.
>> Thanks very much.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. Let's take a question
from the Google Moderator page.
"What upcoming features to Chrome are each
of you most excited about?"
I'll go first. I can take this.
So one of the things that we're working on
in Chrome that I'm most excited about doesn't
necessarily have a name, per se, but it's
just kind of the increasingly personalized
versions of Chrome that you can run.
And so what I mean by that is, currently if
you're using the Chrome synchronization feature,
you can back up all your data to the cloud,
including bookmarks, apps, extensions, auto-fill,
passwords, et cetera, et cetera, and then
you can take that data and you can sync it
across all your devices where you're running
Chrome. Laptops, computers, et cetera.
And so that's great because it enables you
to sync all that -- those personalizations
and customizations across all your installs
of Chrome.
But also in the future, we're working on a
feature where if you happen to share one computer
with multiple people -- suppose you and your
girlfriend or you and your spouse share one
computer -- then obviously you each have your
own personalized Chrome running, your own
tastes, your own preferences, and so it's
kind of hard to switch back and forth.
However, we're working on a feature which
we're internally calling "profiles" which
will allow you to run multiple Chrome windows
side by side, even at the same time, which
each run within their own, you know, kind
of bucket or segment where all the personalized
features, all the sync'd data types, are siloed.
And so that will help you run Chrome side
by side with your spouse on a shared computer
and you can switch back and forth easily and
you can choose which Chrome you want to run.
So I'm pretty excited about that feature.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Well, I got to talk
about some of mine this morning.
The -- probably the one that's coming out
the soonest that I'm most excited about, of
course, is the GPU work. You know, that's
in beta and it's really enabled some amazing
scenarios.
A little bit further out, it's not any specific
feature, it's just the sort of continual improvement
that you're seeing to CSS and to HTML to enable
sort of this more programming in the large,
so that you can write more and more complicated
Web applications. So CSS calc, the shadow
DOM work. There's a ton of stuff in a similar
vein that I think really helps developer productivity,
and so I'm very excited to see how that matures,
you know, over the weeks and months ahead.
>>Kan Liu: I've got lots of features I'm actually
really excited about in Chrome. Everything
from speed itself to file manager work and
a bunch of the new sync types we're going
to add as well. Maybe the one that I'm most
excited about is where we're actually working
on being able to sync your tabs. So I don't
know if any of you use multiple computers.
But I definitely do. And I've got tons and
tons of tabs open all the time and on my laptops
and desktops. And going back and forth is
such a pain just because I always have different
tabs open. And I'm trying to remember which
tab I have open on that machine. So I think
this is going to be a feature that's going
to be really helpful for me personally. So
that's the one I'm most excited about.
>>Erik Kay: I'll just pick two. So, coming
from extensions land, jumping on the sync
front, we're going to allow you to sync data
from within your extensions. So, exporting
an API that allows you to set your -- send
your preferences from computer to computer.
So we think that will enable some really interesting
scenarios. And then, of course, Native Client
will be a lot of fun. And, hopefully, you'll
start seeing that later this year.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. I think I started with
the front microphone last time, so let me
jump to the back microphone.
>>> Will Chrome OS eventually replace Android?
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: You want to answer that?
>>Kan Liu: So -- so I think what you saw today
was -- what Chrome was trying to do is paint
a vision of the future that we believe most
users are going to be taking advantage of,
which is the web. The web is the platform
that we believe is really going to win out
in the long term. So we're trying to create
a computing experience that's optimized for
users of the web. And even other platforms
like Windows and Mac and Android itself. I
think more people are going to be using apps
as well. Access to your information from anywhere,
being able to share easily and all those kind
of things. So I don't know whether -- what
the future of Android looks like or any of
that. I can't speak for them. But one thing
I do know for sure is web is going to continue
to improve. It's going to get better, and
there's going to be more users of it even
on platforms like Android.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: I was going to add,
the web is going to get better on Android
as well as the browser improves there, too.
So it's kind of a little bit of an odd question.
I mean, who knows what the future holds? But
that's certainly not the short-term plans
or near-term plans. We're coming at things,
I think you saw this morning, from very different
directions. So there's plenty of room in this
ecosystem for lots of different innovation.
Obviously, we're focusing on the web side
of things. And Android, as you saw yesterday,
is focusing on a whole ton of equally amazing
scenarios as well. So I think you'll see that
continue.
>>Jeff Chang: Cool. I'll come to the front
microphone and then back to Moderator and
keep circling like that.
>>> Okay. Basically, with the different devices
everyone's carrying around now, interaction
between devices -- home devices, mobile devices
is huge. I've been a huge fan, even when it
was in lab and when it was released as a full
product of Chrome to phone. I wonder if the
framework is there to have Chrome to phone.
I know there are some third-party apps. But
they're clunky and slow and don't work half
the time. But is there any plan for a Google-sanctioned
app that will allow to you go phone to Chrome?
So, if you're browsing something on your phone,
you can toss it to your browser. Like, say,
you wanted to print off a map or something,
you got the navigation on your phone, throw
it to Chrome, and print it from your computer.
Right?
Anything like that?
>>Jeff Chang: That's a pretty interesting
use case. And I've thought about the -- I've
seen Chrome to phone. I've thought about that
use case. But not the one that you described.
That's very interesting though. We'll definitely
be thinking about that.
>>> Are the frameworks there for pushing notification
to Chrome?
>>Erik Kay: Yeah, sync is a mechanism to communicate
back and forth to multiple instances. We continue
to work very closely with the Android team
on a number of things. Right now we don't
have anything on this front. But, you know,
you never know what the future will bring.
>>> Thanks a lot.
>>Jeff Chang: Thank you. We already answered
that one. What hardware requirements do you
enforce for manufacturers to get access to
the Chrome OS source code?
Can anyone use Chromium OS today with the
full Chrome Web Store on any hardware without
asking Google for permission?
>>Trond Wuellner: So today we're working very
tight collaboration with the manufacturers
that we're working with to build Chrome OS.
The hardware requirements that are in place
today are something that we work very carefully
on in order to develop that, develop and deliver
the best experience possible on Chromebooks.
As you look at the Chromium OS source, obviously,
somebody can take that source and build something
they can deliver. I don't see a reason we
would stand in the way of that. As far as
the first Chromebooks, we want to work closely
with the manufacturers to make sure the experience
is as good as possible with the users. We're
excited about continuing to extend that in
the future.
>>Erik Kay: Just one last addition to that
is asking about the web store. And we don't
have any restrictions on who can visit the
web store. It's just a Web site.
>>Jeff Chang: Microphone in the back now.
>>> Hi. I'm really concerned about privacy
and security. And I was wanting to hear some
reassurance about the way that you install
extensions and web apps. Particularly, when
I see a weather-type app asking for access
to my entire web history or my entire file
system data. That sounds kind of scary. And,
even in the help system, it says that you
should be concerned about an app asking for
that much permissions. Will you look to giving
more granular permissions to the user to have
more control over what the app has access
to rather than me having to make a tradeoff
of giving my entire history to an app that's,
basically, for example, providing me weather?
>>Erik Kay: Sure. So, you know, this is something
we care an awful lot about. So in the extensions
team, this year, in particular, you know,
when we first started and designed it, we
really spent an awful lot of time thinking
about security. And we really feel that we
advanced the state-of-the-art. It went from
an all-or-nothing thing where it's, effectively,
an extension is executable where it had full
access to your computer and anything it can
do to something that was more granular. And
it is possible for developers to write something
that is more granular, doesn't need all the
scary permissions in the world. That said,
we're not content to rest there. And we have
many innovations that we're working on that
we think are going to improve things in the
next year. Things like, for example, some
of the reasons why extension authors ask for
all these permissions are, actually, sometimes
for power user features within their extension.
And a feature that only 5% of their users
use, yet it requires all of their users to
say yes to that permission.
So one thing that we're going to be adding
in the near future is something we're calling
an optional permission where it can sort of
split up its permissions into a set of here
are the ones required for use, here are the
ones we can enable on-demand so that most
users don't even need to see that or be bothered
by that. Other things we're looking at are
ways to allow users and enterprise admins
to exclude access to certain Web sites for
extensions. So, for example, maybe you say
you trust this extension in general; but you
don't want any extension to ever access your
bank. And, you know, that kind of thing.
There's a lot more that we're thinking about
on this front. And so, yes, don't expect us
to rest. Expect to see a series of improvements
on this front from us.
>>> Can I add to that?
From your answer, it sounded like it was more
developer-centric rather than user-centric.
I was wondering if -- it sounded like you
were saying you would give the developer the
option of making optional security versus
giving the power to the user in having that
choice rather than solely on the developer
side.
>>Erik Kay: Well, the power -- there's a couple
of issues here. And one is the -- we're relying
on the web store to act as a dampening factor
for stuff. When users don't like what an extension
is doing and an author is doing, one of the
things that works is people give negative
reviews and give feedback saying they don't
want it to do what it's doing. They want it
to act in a more constrained fashion.
The more general question what you're asking
is for users to be able to block certain permissions
selectively to be able to pick and choose
which of the permissions an extension can
or can't do. And this is a conscious choice
by us to not do that. The reason being it's
a question of testing and stability for the
developers. The developer builds an app with
the expectation that it's going to work a
certain way; that having certain things, you
know, sort of, you know, arbitrary permutations
of the capabilities disabled out from under
it is sort of an untenable quality situation
for developers to be put into.
So, yes, at the end of the day, that part
is a developer choice. However, you know,
like I said, the -- we think that the feedback
and the reputation in the store feeds back
on itself quite positively on that front and
that, as we roll out these features, you know,
that more and more developers are going to
adopt it. Now, just one clarification, there
are a couple features where the user is in
control in places where, you know, it doesn't,
you know, affect the overall functionality,
for example. You know, an extension will never
have access to incognito or file URLs without
your explicit permission. And the other example
I used about blocking access to specific sites
would be something that would be totally in
your control. Okay. Why don't we -- I spent
a lot of time on that one.
>>Jeff Chang: Microphone in the front.
>>> There's a question about Chrome Frame
deployment. As a web developer, I can't wait
to not having to worry about IE6. But, as
the previous question talked about, it's awful
hard to get people to install it. And, if
people haven't, you still have this problem.
I'm surprised that more Google apps haven't
prompted people to install. And I'm sure they
could be a big champion for this. I'm thinking
developers hate IE6 as much as anybody else.
I'm thinking of GMail or apps where it really
would be a more improved experience if you
were on a more modern browser. Do you know
why haven't prompted it yet?
Is Chrome Frame not ready yet or they're lazy
or have trouble getting people to install
it? Or what can we do to help them help us?
>>Alex Russell: Great question. I want to
defend my colleagues on the apps teams. They're
not lazy. In fact, they work very hard on
the user experience. This is a question of
helping them liberate themselves from those
constraints. Application teams in Google also
live under the edict of "thou shalt be fast."
We do too. If they can't say we're not going
to regress your latency or performance, it's
not a viable option for them. Because of the
complicated performance picture for Chrome
Frame, until very recently it's been a little
bit of a tossup to try to do testing because
there's cold start versus warm start. There's
low latency connections versus high latency
connections. You have to run an experiment.
It takes a lot of time to sort of figure that
out. Luckily Pat and the test.org guys have
put together support for Chrome Frame on the
pagetest.org that is helping us prove that
on most sites Chrome Frame is a net win. It's
not going to degrade your performance. That's
the sort of data that helps us make a credible
argument that both internally and externally
that Chrome Frame isn't just a good idea in
terms of liberating you from your current
constraints about the sorts of features you
can deliver, but it's also a viable way to
help you meet your latency goals and, certainly,
at a minimum, not regress. So that is maybe
the largest predicate for why they haven't
been prompting so far. And I'm hopeful that
we'll see a lot more of that both externally
and internally at Google, because a lot of
sites can benefit.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. We have a Google Moderator
question. What's the next step for Chrome
from the UI standpoint?
So I previously mentioned that we're continuing
to work on sync, so you can sync your browser
settings and preferences and data to the cloud
across all your devices. As Kan mentioned,
we're working on adding new data types such
as new tabs. So that will be exciting. And
of course user profiles, as I mentioned, so
you'll be able to run multiple personalized
versions of Chrome on the same machine. But
there's other areas of the UI that we're working
on. We recently started working on revamping
the new tab page. We're always kind of constantly
thinking how we can make that as useful as
possible for our users. We're trying to think
through the right balance in terms of how
customizable it is versus, you know, what
kind of magic formulas we use to show you
content on your tab page, whether that be
your bookmarks or the apps you installed from
the web store or the pages you visit the most
or the recent pages you visited or recent
tabs you have open on any of your devices.
So definitely looking forward to continuing
to work on the new tab page from a UI standpoint.
Okay. So I think it's back microphone now.
>>> With the Chrome OS and Android all being
open source, one of the biggest challenges
for Google seems to be digital rights management.
What is the team doing as a whole to improve
that?
We still don't have applications like Netflix,
which has been on the iPhone for a very long
time. You know, when and what is the Chrome
team doing to improve DRM for, you know, providers
of it, so that way we can get more content
on the devices?
>>Kan Liu: Good question. So today we already
support Flash DRM. So, obviously, YouTube
movie rentals and all that stuff work already.
We've been working closely with Netflix as
well. In fact, we announced today that out
of the box, when you get your Chrome OS device,
Netflix will work. So we've been working with
them on that as well.
I don't know, generally, on other platforms
Chrome has done anything unique or special,
though.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: No.
>>Jeff Chang: Microphone in the front.
>>> Kind of taking it from the reverse angle,
I'm a great Chrome fan. And I'd love to get
rid of all the other browsers on my machine.
But, every once in a while, once a month I
have to do reports using FedEx. And I have
to do plane bookings. And I do some real estate
stuff with various MLSs, all programmed in
wonderfully rich, ancient frameworks. And
they don't work on Chrome.
Are you guys continuing to figure out what
to do with those huge legacy, heavy-duty apps
that are all over the place?
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Yeah. It's -- obviously,
it's a huge problem sort of dealing with legacy.
And there's no easy answer. I mean, obviously,
we look at Chrome Frame and other solutions
like that to provide us an escape valve.
So you can continue to run old applications
until they, frankly, just die off. And that,
I know, can take, you know, a decade or more.
I think we've been helped recently just -- there's
something of a perfect storm going on right
now with HTML5 with IE, with Firefox and Chrome
really focusing heavily on HTML5 features.
And it's creating this pull now for apps to
get updated and rewritten to be sort of more
modern. And that's helping accelerate the
demise of some of the older browsers and with
it some of the older applications. So it's
a huge challenge, and we look at ways to help
mitigate the issue on both sides to try to
find ways to help developers migrate to HTML5
modern browsers, modern era browsers, and
also to create demand. That the experience
is so much better on a more modern platform.
The developers are motivated. And users and
IT departments are motivated to move to something
else. And time will take care of these things.
But we will try and accelerate them as much
as possible. I wish there was a magic bullet
that we could just sort of rewrite history.
Unfortunately, we don't have anything quite
that magical yet. Maybe we'll -- I don't know,
we have to go one at a time and go kidnap
the people that wrote those apps. And I don't
know. We'll find some magical solution, maybe.
>>Erik Kay: One other thing I'll toss out
is in the web kit community, compatibility
issues are treated very seriously. They're
high priority things when they can get nailed
down. That said, there are a class of compatibility
bugs that, for a variety of reasons, have
been deemed hard to fix in a way that doesn't
cause other problems. And, if you think compatibility
problems are bad with legacy stuff here, you
should just go to China or Korea where some
of the dependency on IE is an -- old features
of IE is pretty, you know, endemic. And within
their -- in addition to fixing web kit bugs,
we've spent, actually, a fair amount of time
building tools to help Web site authors track
down the compatibility issues that they've
got. So, for example, the China team has put
together a tool that you can point at your
Web site. And it just highlights all the things
and says this is an IE dependency. This is
an IE dependency. It's a very important issue
to us and one that we continue to push on.
>>Jeff Chang: Will Google Chrome on Linux
Ubuntu support WebGL?
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Actually, I thought
that was an obvious "yes." But now I'm panicked
that there's a question. I'm going to look
at the front row. (off mic) I'm hearing from
Ian that with new drivers you should be okay.
But let us check offline and double-check
if we're giving you the correct information
there. I don't know off the top of my head.
So let us find out and we'll get back to you.
Thanks.
>>Jeff Chang: Now I think it's to the back.
>>> Yeah. I had questions about Chrome OS
and the native client support. Will that enable
me to do things like, if I wanted to implement
a new video or audio streaming protocol, would
that allow me to support that on Chrome OS,
or how would I do something like that?
>>Erik Kay: Sure. The point of Native Client
is, you know, to allow you to take your expertise
and your history with native code and be able
to port it safely. Chrome OS is one of those.
Without knowing more about your specific use
case, I can't tell you whether you're porting
job will be harder or easier than other porting
cases. If, for example, you're talking about
building a video codec, that would be really
easy. Usually, they're just operating in memory
bytes and that sort of thing. If you're talking
about you want specific low-level access to
the network stack, well, that one might be
a little harder because, you know, there are
security issues involved there. And Native
Client, kind of the whole -- the other point
of this is because we're trying to deliver
this securely, you know, it's only through
the set of APIs that we expose. And that will
be -- you know, we need to lock down some
of the things to prevent people from doing,
you know, bad things with that.
>>> Okay, Thank you.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. In the front.
>>> Two questions. One, really excited about
Chromebook and the way you guys are approaching
Chrome OS as well as a browser.
As part of the sync protocol, is there any
plans on making available a co-browsing type
of a capability which allows administrators
or whomever to -- or app administrators to
figure out what issues their apps are having
where they can see side by side what the user
is seeing within Chrome for their specific
app?
Second question: Excited about Chromebook.
And trying to find out when's Canada going
to get one.
[ Laughter ]
We seem to be left behind in a lot of things
from Google. So...
>>Trond Wuellner: So while we don't have any
explicit date for Canada, one of the things
we are really pushing pretty aggressively
on is to try to get as much international
support as we absolutely can as quickly as
possible. It is on our short list of really
important places to get to quickly.
>>Erik Kay: So with regard to the first question,
it is something we've looked at but I don't
think we have anything to announce at this
time.
>>> Do you know if the capability is there,
or is that something that would have to be
built? I have a specific use case, and that's
why I'm asking.
>>Erik Kay: Well, you have seen probably work
on us being able to do some remote desktop
type of stuff. So it is in theory possible.
But, again, I don't think there is much that
we can talk about in detail here.
>>> Okay, thank you.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay.
Is it Google Moderator now? Chrome was revolutionary
when it came out. Thanks. Well, actually I
can't take credit. But now it's a mature platform
that evolves and iterates. What's your vision
of the next revolutionary thing coming to
the browser market?
I have said this a number of times already.
But I really think this notion of synchronizing
your browsing experience across all your devices
is very compelling. I think -- and I hope
that the browser market continues to think
about what kinds of things make up a personalized
browsing experience and what kind of things
can be synced. For example, recent tabs is
one example. We should be able to basically
think of the browser as our window into the
computing experience that we want no matter
where we are and what machine or what device
we're using.
>>Erik Kay: So, you know, one way of thinking
about this is that we tackled, you know -- we
had four core principles with Chrome, right:
Speed, security, simplicity, security, right?
And we -- oops, did I repeat one? Sorry. I
said security twice.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: It matters that much.
>>Erik Kay: Security is that important to
us.
Stability was the other one that I left off,
sorry.
So, anyway, we think that focusing on these
four issues and really, you know, putting
a lot of weight behind all of them led to
a lot of the revolutionary aspects.
And the thing is that once we got there, these
principles didn't go away in importance. They're
still there. And we think that there's a lot
of room to go in all of them.
So on the security front, you know, we're,
you know, working to get, you know, all of
our plug-ins fully Sandboxed. And Chrome OS
is pushing -- pushing the boundaries there.
And on the simplicity front, you know, we're
continuing to streamline RUI and make more
interesting features just available without
users even thinking. Complicated use cases
like Jeff was talking about about a shared
computer, you know, how easy can we make that?
Or synchronization of data, can we make that
seamless? How much faster can we make things?
I think there are a lot of things we can continue
to make faster.
So, you know -- I don't know. Maybe focusing
on the same core things doesn't sound revolutionary.
But to us, we think that these are the things
that unlock those sort of next level of uses.
>>Alex Russell: From the Web developer perspective,
Chrome was revolutionary in terms of speed.
I think the next thing that I'm excited about
there is that we have so much that we've been
pouring into the platform over the past couple
of years, that's not evenly distributed yet.
It is not clear today that you can start your
next project and target the features that
are just in Chrome now.
And when that becomes reality for developers,
it is going to change the way you build applications.
It is going to change the kinds of applications
you build. And we just haven't seen the full
impact of that yet. So I think as we continue
to simplify what it means to build an app,
that's going to happen concurrently with us
sort of having that moment like it was with
Ajax where we go, Whoa, you can do that in
a browser? And that's just going to take some
time. I'm really excited to see that pass.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. To the back again.
>>> Yeah, I just have an example scenario.
So let's say we have screens all over the
building here that are all showing some sort
of Web app. Is there any way like on the browser
level as opposed to, like, doing it from a
Web app standpoint of synchronizing all of
those screens together? Are you guys working
at all on something to not only sync the browsing
experience for a personal user but to synchronize
the browsing experience for some sort of digital
display type of thing?
>>Alex Russell: So I think from the platform
perspective, WebSockets are the next closest
thing. So you can have a reflector server
which you can send events to and folks who
listen in on those events. Those can drive
a shared Web app experience.
Some of the folks who were showing apps in
the Sandbox are doing exactly that with WebSockets.
They are getting really low latency collaborative
games to happen. You need to share a data
model. So working in the data space is important.
And then you need to share a low-level latency
channel for that.
It is up to the app to do that, but those
are the bits of the stack that you need to
deliver that sort of experience.
>>> Okay. Thank you very much.
>>Jeff Chang: And to the front.
>>> Yeah, my question is about developer tools.
Are there any plans to make dev tools more
extendable? Like, if I want to write an extension
for my own company for the project I'm working
on?
>>Pavel Feldman: We have just announced the
extensibility for Chrome dev tools on the
session today at 1:00 p.m or something. So
check out our site at code.google.com/chrome/devtools
and you can find info there.
>>> That's great.
And second question, which is not a follow-up,
but anyway, with Traceur, if I am pronounced
that correctly, is it going to be more native
to Chrome and to developer tools at some point
where I can actually debug it with developer
tools and not to debug the compiled JavaScript?
>>Alex Russell: So the way for that to happen
is for those features to get through get through
the standards process and into V8, at which
point that will be the next experience.
>>> Only through the standards process?
>>Alex Russell: I think that's maybe the easiest
way. I know that there is line-for-line debugging
from source to compiled stuff happening in
other browsers. I don't know where that's
at.
>>Pavel Feldman: We kind of have generic schema
for debugging compiled languages, but we should
wait for the platform to get there in this
work case. But we will have support for compiled
languages for (inaudible) and closure and
get them debugged on the dev tools.
>>> Okay, thanks.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. So will we be able to
download and install Chrome OS when it comes
out?
>>Trond Wuellner: So anybody today can go
to chromium.org and download virtually every
bit of source code that's involved in Chrome
OS. There is a handful of things we don't
have the license to publish in that place,
but everything else is there.
So you can go install Get, pull it down, build
it, install it today on a wide variety of
different systems.
A number of developers have taken that chromium.org
source code and delivered flavors of this.
One of my personal favorites is one that Hexa
delivered that can put on a number of different
books today. Phenomenal experience.
That's the route we are going to go with for
people downloading themselves.
As far as official Chrome OS going on to as
a downloadable and installable application,
that's unlikely to happen. We are working
very closely with our hardware partners to
deliver the best possible user experience,
and there are a number of things that going
into doing that well. And that's what we are
going to focus on there.
>>Kan Liu: Just add to that a little bit,
one of the reasons why we have to work very
closely with hardware partners and get very
specific bits for that is because we actually
integrate all the way down to the firmware.
So there's very hardware specific pieces of
code that you won't just be able to download
and run on any machine because of the way
that we actually do verified boot, for example.
So a lot of the security relies on this. So
we could make that available for download,
but it wouldn't really run on any other system
and you wouldn't get the same benefits of
security and performance and so forth.
So that's actually why it wouldn't make sense
for us to just put partner code on a server
somewhere for everyone to download.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. Microphone in the back.
>>> I just had a question about: Have you
guys thought about supporting Google Go for
the Native Client?
>>Erik Kay: So, let's see. Last year we did
a preview release, sort of an experimental
release of Native Client. And as part of that,
the Go team had done a port that ran on top
of it.
Now, they have since -- We went through a
bunch of big changes last year, changed the
whole browser integration API that we used.
So the Go team stepped back from that to wait
for us to stabilize and finish before they
came back.
But my understanding was that it wasn't a
particularly challenging port, so I don't
expect a problem coming forward.
There are a number of people doing other languages
to Native Client. In general, the rule is,
you know, if it can be compiled, we can put
it into Native Client.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. To the front.
>>> Yeah. Just a quick question. Any ETA on
bringing Canary to Linux?
>>Jeff Chang: So I think in general -- So
I'm not sure. But for Linux users, we -- I
guess we tend to assume they're a bit savvier.
And it is pretty easy to run a nightly build.
I don't know. I don't know the answer to that
question. Sorry.
>>Erik Kay: So I know that somebody is -- outside
of Google is maintaining -- I think it is
Popcorn, is like this -- a distro tool for
Ubuntu that somebody is using to maintain
like a dev -- sort of an equivalent to dev,
beta, stable and canary builds of Chrome.
So we're not doing it.
One of the challenges of doing this sort of
thing for Linux is just all the different
distros and configurations we need to support.
But we might do it ourselves in the future
for Canary, but I don't know what the plans
are on that front.
>>> Okay, thanks.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. What do you think about
the interaction between tabbed browsers and
tiling window managers? What is the future
of tabbed browsing?
Well, I think in general, you know, we're
very happy to see that tabbed browsing is
definitely making its way into the rest of
the browser market and users, I believe, find
that to be, you know, a compelling experience.
On Chrome specifically, we are experimenting
around with a few different ways to present
tabs and some window management stuff as well.
But we haven't made any decision on that front
yet. In general, we've actually found that
our data shows that the majority of users
are for -- the vast majority of page loads,
most users don't have that many tabs open.
And so it is a very good question whether
that's because -- So, basically, we are thinking
hard about the problem of having lots and
lots of tabs open. But we really haven't made
a decision how to proceed yet, but it is definitely
an area that we are open to experimenting
with.
>>Kan Liu: I will quickly add to that. I do
think the current window manager system on
most operating systems today is kind of broken,
all right?
The fact that I'm constantly having to go
and manage my windows myself, I always have
these overlapping windows. I'm trying to find
content behind something. I'm rearranging
things to get something out of the way of
something else.
It's way more cognitive load as a user for
me than I really want to -- care about. I
just basically want my content when I want
it. I want to be able to pace between things,
compare things and all of that kind of stuff.
The window manager should really take care
of most of this for me.
I think this is an area, like Jeff was saying,
that we're going to do a lot more investigation
on. And stay tuned because I think we have
some interesting ideas here that we are going
to be showing soon.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. In the front?
>>> Hey. So I hear you have been talking a
lot about syncing the tabs. And I was wondering
if you were planning on doing that in a realtime
kind of syncing or maybe on opening the window?
>>Jeff Chang: That's a good question. As you
can imagine, if you have a bunch of tabs open
here and then you close one here and all of
a sudden it immediately closed on the other
machine and someone else is there, it is going
to be like what the...
We have been thinking hard about that. We
are not currently not assuming that we will
just sync everything everywhere exactly the
same but rather present some sort of view
of recent tabs. That might be recent tabs
you have interacted with on other machines
or recent tabs that you have closed.
We are just in the initial stages, but we
are going to be trying it ourselves to see
what kind of magical formula works or not.
And we will definitely be iterating on that.
>>> That makes a lot of sense. Also, what's
with the new flat icon? Why?
>>Erik Kay: So it turned out that, I don't
know, none of us actually really loved the
early icon, it turned out. It was a compromise
between not being able to find a better one.
And one of the things -- we grew to love it
over time; but, you know, early on it was
kind of a love-hate thing.
What we found, though, is as time went on
and we kept putting the logo in different
places, that every sort of -- every artist,
every place we put it put a slightly different
take on it. And it was getting morphed around
partly because that 3D-rendered look wasn't
very flexible for being put in different form
factors, like put on a T-shirt or put on a
Frisbee or put on a poster or -- or different
art styles and whatever.
And so at the end of the day, it just found
-- turned out that having a flatter style
was more adaptable to a bunch of different
places we wanted to do it.
>>> Okay, thank you.
>>Jeff Chang: Personally I really like the
icon. I think it is more symmetrical and it
spins better. So like on Frisbees and stuff
like that it looks better.
I tried to get Frisbees for you guys for the
conference, but it didn't work out.
Let's go to the back microphone, and then
I'll go back to the Moderator.
>>> So the HTML5 video formats, the effort
to standardize those was spoiled by a couple
of bad apples.
And is the Chrome team planning on being a
little bit more insistent on audio and image
formats? Or have you guys just decided to
let the market sort it out and support whatever
becomes de facto standard?
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Well, we've obviously
gotten very prescriptive for Chrome and with
the support for WebM. I don't see that changing.
You know, we support other formats through
plug-ins, and I think that will continue.
But if you are going to have a format that
can be used as part of the Web standards,
specifically I'm talking about the video tag,
then it needs to be a royalty-free, open standard.
And right now WebM is that. If there is more
to come down the line, fantastic.
>>> Theora already came. You guys could support
that, and that would give you the three out
of five majority required to make Theora a
standard format.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: I'm told that Theora
is supported.
>>> Not as a plug-in but in core?
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: In core. Yeah, yeah.
>>> Fantastic.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Thanks.
>>> Thank you.
>>Jeff Chang: Let's do microphone in the front.
>>> With all the browser integration and syncing
between multiple browsers, is there any thoughts
or ideas on how to differentiate where the
information was synced from?
So say I put a bookmark in on the mobile device,
is there a way to -- on my Chrome at home,
to be able to see that, Hey, I was looking
for a link that I remember I put it in on
my phone and see that it was actually brought
in from my mobile device as opposed to just
a random link stuck in all the rest of them?
That kind of thing, if that makes sense.
>>Jeff Chang: That's a very good point. We'll
definitely be thinking about for which use
cases that makes sense for.
For example, for recent tabs you obviously
do want to see which device the recent tab
came from. We are thinking about the best
way to present that information, how to specify
the device that it came from. So yes.
>>> Thank you.
>>Jeff Chang: We are running out of time.
Let's get through a couple more. Can you explain
which parts of the browser are shared or not
shared between Webkit, Safari and Chrome?
Also, which all of those bodies should I submit
a bug when I find one?
>>Alex Russell: So Webkit is a kernel for
a browser. It is not the whole thing. The
way Webkit works is you say, Hey, Webkit,
I'm navigating to this URL or Webkit maybe
asks you, Please navigate to this URL. You
respond with content. And Webkit asks a whole
series of follow-up questions to you to help
service the requests for everything from low-level
network access to storage access to rendering.
And all those bits are things that people
who port Webkit wind up plugging in their
own solutions for or, in some cases, using
one of the default solutions that's in Webkit
to the extent that they exist.
So we share sort of all the layout and rendering
guts that Webkit asks -- that form the engine
that causes Webkit to ask us questions back
in response for. And then we plug in our own
pieces where you would otherwise need to plug
in your own pieces. There are some things
like V8 versus JavaScript core where we've
decided to go our own way. But generally speaking,
we are plugging into the parts of Webkit where
any porter would have to do exactly the same
thing.
>>Erik Kay: So I think the one -- this is
a common problem people have, is that actually
knowing where to file the bug is kind of tricky.
And if you're a browser engineer like we are,
it is obvious. Oh, of course, that is in the
networking layer so that must be Chrome's
bug.
You know, but in reality, it takes practice
to sort of figure out, tease out which layer
the problem is at.
So the best thing I can suggest is to save
yourself some time. You know, don't bother
trying to file it separately in all three
places. Just pick one, take a guess. And what
will happen is if you are wrong, you know,
the people who are triaging the bugs will
guide you to the right place.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: I was just going to
add that, I mean, this happens to me all the
time because I'm the new guy, and all I typically
do is I'll just do a search in one of them
to sort of just see, you know, (a) if that
bug has already been reported or (b) if there's
an area. And often you can quickly find, "Oh,
look, here's the technology area and here's,
you know, how to classify the bug," and also
kind of like what kind of information you
should add to the bug report, so that, you
know, people can track it down, whether it's
in Chromium or Webkit.
And, you know, it only takes like 30 seconds
to do it, to do a search, and that helps narrow
it down.
If in doubt, just enter the bug somewhere,
because it's better to enter a bug than not.
>>Pavel Feldman: So the rule I use is, when
I don't know where to file the bug, you have
the best chances if you are filing it as -- against
yourbug.com. Just file it against Chrome and
it will make its way to Webkit or not. If
it is, in fact, a Webkit bug, developers,
engineers, are going to submit a bug in Webkit,
handle it, and then triage it back to Chrome
to make sure it's marked as fixed.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. We're over time now so
let me just get the last question from the
audience and then we'll wrap it up.
>> Hello. Since there is native plug-ins,
like the NP API, we can use to create any
plug-ins we want, how can NaCl, since it's
sandbox, access what we could do before?
Because if I want to access a desktop API
in Windows or Linux or Mac, we cannot do that
right now.
Are you planning to -- like what are we limited
in with Native Client or Pepper 2, since it's
sandbox right now?
>>Erik Kay: Sure. There's some use cases that
Native Client just isn't going to be able
to address, and if you're looking for something
which is going to access directly some low-level
OS feature, you know, Native Client isn't
going to do that for you.
You're going to have to use, you know, NP
API and, you know, older technologies for
that, you know, and come with all the security
pitfalls that go along with that.
In general, if you're accessing the low-level
interfaces, you're bypassing all the security
checks, so, you know, putting it in Native
Client wouldn't help.
Now, that said, we are, you know, going to
be continuing to grow and expand the pepper
APIs, and essentially anything that we're
going to expose in the web browser in some
form or another, we'll expose to Native Client.
So for example, if we add access to a webcam
and microphone in the web browser, we would
add access to that in Native Client as well.
But access to, you know, a particular, you
know, kernel interface or, you know, the Windows
Explorer plug-in or whatever else, you're
unlikely to find that from us.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay. Thanks, everyone, for
coming, and enjoy the rest of the conference.